i've been wondering lately
tell me if i'm wrong but i listened to
the daily a lot you know the new york
times um with michael barbaro and there
are times you know about this matt but
it's a suspicion i'm a big fan of the
daily and i it's like a regular part of
my day and there are times where i swear
to god i listen to it and i think that
it's possible
that uh
they get someone talking for a while
and then afterwards in audio they just
have michael barbaro go mm-hmm
uh-huh
huh they have a bank they have a bank
and it's occurred to me and then
basically he they have him recap so
what happens is they get the person
talking for a while and he basically
says there was this uh apparently this
woman named goldilocks who went in
and uh there were
three bowls of porridge and uh there was
one that was too hot
and there was one that was too cold but
then there was one that was uh just
right so what you're saying
is that
this young girl goldilocks went into
uh she went into a house a house that
she had not been in before and there
were three bowls of uh of porridge
one two hot one too cold and and one
just right and which one did she choose
well good question she chose the one
that was just right
ah
yeah then she went into the next room
and there was a bed there were three
beds one was too firm one was too soft
and one was just right so what you're
saying is that then she went to another
room and there were three beds one was
too hard one was too soft and one was
just right did she choose one of those
beds she did very good question and it
was the one that was just right at any
point you might ask did the bears come
home they did they actually did come
home and that's what i was gonna get to
next
the three bears came home and they found
goldilocks asleep in the bed so what
you're saying is the goldilocks fell
asleep in the bed and the three bears
come in
and they encountered goldilocks what
happened then
excellent question uh they uh they awoke
goldilocks she was surprised and she ran
out the door and she was never heard
from again
incredible okay here's what else you
need to know today
in canada a large fat of syrup exploded
flooding oregon we go now i i believe
that's the general thing and i'm feeling
like i could i swear to god i don't need
to be par i don't need to be here with
the guests anymore as much as i love it
i i feel like i could be
you could
let them just babble and then um
send me little prompt questions and i
can finally live out my dream
of living in a little one of those
little ice fishing shacks you know where
they cut a hole in the ice
and i i live there all alone and i grow
just a crazy beard yeah do you know how
to fix no and i don't even like fishing
and i don't like the cold but it's it's
an image that i like and that's what i'm
gonna do and then every now and then i'm
gonna get on the phone and matt's gonna
say all right all you have to do is ask
these three questions about goldilocks
and you're off the hook
so
what you're saying is that this
bear this blue bear which is uh quite
unusual was started out in canada and
then came down to oregon uh what does
this mean
and then the person goes on and says and
the hammerhead sharks attacked the
supermodels is that what you're saying
are you talking like michael barbaro now
i mean i'm channeling i'm channeling him
a little bit you know he has that way he
hears yeah you need to know today and
then he goes here's your note today but
he puts in eight seconds yes yes no i've
actually i have i have a game where when
michael barbaro does the uh introduction
i try to see if i can make a tuna melt
during the gap so he goes i'm going to
borrow bailey
and here's
and i try i quickly run and i get rye
bread i put in the toaster and you know
i won't take you through the whole thing
but i've made most of a sandwich and
sometimes i've made the whole sandwich
and eaten half of it before he says
what you need to know today that's good
you could probably make up
matt
a bunch of things
audio cues that you play almost like on
a keyboard and we could do a podcast
where i'm just reacting and i know you
i know you you're going to sometimes
screw me over because someone's gonna
say yeah it was really tough because
that was the year i lost my father
[Laughter]
i think i think you should record a
bunch of stuff you say often
yeah when i was at saturday night live
or well i'm like picasso and you know
you don't tell michelangelo how to paint
like his body yeah look at this body
here yeah when i say look at this body
it's usually with fear and sadness
it's yeah it's more like if you don't
behave i'm gonna take off my shirt and
then you're really gonna see
what 80 year old spam looks like if it's
fresh out of the can my father just
passed away look at this body
i guess what i'm trying to say is that
listening to the daily gave me this idea
that we could probably
yeah i could spend a day one full day
giving you every single conanism and
every single human reaction and then god
forbid something ever happens to me
this podcast goes on in perpetuity you
sit there at a synthesizer and you just
play or not even something happens to me
i just become incredibly lazy and and a
hermit so you just sit there matt and
they're like when you have another
episode you know who's on uh who's on
this time what's marissa tomei okay
get marissa to me in a room and have her
tell five stories and you're just
sitting there and you're playing like
oh i see yeah
wow that's rough
murderer
corn cob soup i'm picasso
uh look at my body
i used to work on saturday night live
i could do that now i could just take
those sound bites from previous podcasts
uh you could but i want it i want it to
be a whole day in the studio i want it
to spend cost a lot of money
i want to have uh i want it directed by
a famous director
oh really yeah what are you thinking uh
i don't know your cameron's kirk cameron
yeah kirk cameron okay i want him to
direct this
and also be my religious uh director no
i don't know i don't know what i'm
saying but um i think we could work that
out i think we can make a whole
podcast with you just never saying
anything yeah and i think that that's a
goal we should strive for anyway think
about this
just uh and
and then we could i think start cranking
out hundreds of episodes a week that's
another bonus i can't but then i have to
edit all that and put that all together
what are you doing picking out a
whatever new weird tchotchke to have in
the background of your zoom shot okay
stop with camel no one has a bigger
collection of straw
hats from the turn of the century than
mike uh than matthew gourley mike who's
mike
he's the guy i can replace you with
[Laughter]
he's really great i keep we have one
more meeting with him sax and i and then
he's on board he's fantastic oh i wish
him well yeah mike galaginsky fantastic
guy